hi there today we'll look at context or
CNN long-term temporal context for per
camera object detection by Sarah Barry
Guan Hong woo vivek Rathod Rani Votel
and Jonathan Wong so on a high level
this paper tries to do object detection
for cameras where you the camera is in
the same place for a long time for
example these wild trap cameras or
traffic cameras right here it proposes
to do object detection by incorporating
data from the images that the camera has
seen in the past to help the detection
in the current frame and it does so via
an attention mechanism that it runs over
a memory of past data so we're going to
take a look at how this is done and how
well it works and yes take around if you
want to know as always if you enjoy
content like this then consider sharing
it out telling your friends about it
subscribe if you haven't and tell me
what you think in the comments so the
paper starts off and describes the
problem and the problem is fairly simple
you want to do object detection in
images object detection is the task of
basically if you if I give you an image
you should tell me what is on the image
and where so in this case here you would
have to draw me this bounding box and
say this is a deer on the bottom you
would have to draw bounding boxes maybe
they have to be rectangular maybe not
and say this is a bus and here is a
truck and here is another truck and here
is a car and so on so there can be many
objects in an image there can be one
object there can be objects of different
classes or there can be no objects at
all so this is just object detection and
there have been many papers on this and
specifically there has been this our CNN
and this is the model that we're going
to extend so the our CNN model or
specifically the faster our CNN model
that we're going to build on is a model
that same
detect these bounding boxes in signal in
single images but now we consider the
situation where we have a camera that
records images for a long long time so
in these wild trap cameras they often
sit there for months and it's not that
easy to make use of them because in
addition to there being a lot of data
they have motion triggers so that could
be there is no nothing for a long time
and then there's a B the animal walks in
the trap and then you have a bunch of
images like one per second for ten
seconds and then you have nothing again
for like a day or two days and then you
have ten images again because another
animal walks in or maybe doesn't and so
on and another so you have irregular
sampling frequencies you have very very
different distance between the frames
all of this makes it very very not
suited for models like temporal
convolutions or things like LST M's
because they don't work super well with
data like this now I know there are
formulations where LST M's can do this
but they don't work very well with these
super long contexts and irregular
sampling frequencies and so on so the
idea is if we have a frame right here
like this one and we want to detect
what's on it we should be able to pull
information from other frames that the
same camera has seen like from this one
or from this one or from this one right
here and we should be able to do so in a
dynamic way now why could that help if
you look at for example down here these
images have been taken they say
images were taken on separate days but
you can see this thing right here is in
both images so or a very similar thing
is probably that buses regular route so
in in order to classify if whether or
not this here it is a bus it might be
very helpful to also look at this
picture right here and see all in you
know its
about at the same location it looks the
same and also it looks like a bus so you
know that that kind of gives evidence
that this could be this other thing
could also be a bus then also there are
background objects so sometimes the
single frame detectors get confused it
might be labeling this here as a car
because just the lighting the exact
lighting in this picture is just off by
the correct amount that it is confused
but considering this picture over here
maybe it recognizes here no that's not a
car and it can bring over this evidence
to that frame and and consider ah maybe
maybe you know this is the same thing so
it's it's not a car so this is this is
not the same then simply adding training
data we really consider the fact here
that these images they come from the
same camera that is in the same location
or maybe you know that is filming the
same thing so this all of this is going
to be within the same camera not just
adding adding iid training data and with
animals as well like often the same
animal has like its regular route or
within these ten these bursts of tens
the same as animal will kind of walk
around a bit and maybe you know here
it's half occluded but maybe in a
different image you see aha here I see
the nose so it helps you make a better
prediction also animals are often in
kind of crowds in and and that helps if
you see that there are other deer around
the probability that this is a deer
increases rapidly so how are we going to
do this what we're going to do is we're
going to build an attention mechanism
that can do these kinds of look into the
past and some also a little bit of the
future as we will see but mainly we'll
look into other images from the same
camera in a dynamic way and we'll learn
how to address those other
images from a memory bank so the
architecture is described right here now
as you can see we are still in the
business of doing object detection so
what we'll do is we'll sort of hijack a
existing object detector and the object
detector we're going to hijack is going
to be this F or CNN this faster or CNN
object detector that's an object
detector detector for a single frame
problem so that means you have one image
and you're supposed to detect what's on
it it has two stages as you can see so
stage one if you have an image and let's
say there's some stuff on it
stuff stuff stuff there stuff okay this
what stage one is supposed to do is it
supposed to extract regions of interest
this could be okay all of these are
regions of interest so it simply says
well there is something there might be
something right here in these regions of
interest and then it describes each of
these regions of interest using features
okay so it extracts these regions of
interest and each region of interest
gets features assigned to it so well
these are I think these are like 7 by 7
by by 2048 features but let's just say
for the sake of the describing it that
these are just a vector of features for
each region of interest so each region
of interest is going to be associated
with one vector of features that this
model extracts ok and the next region of
interest also has a vector and the next
region of interest also has a vector and
so on stage 2 then takes each one of
these takes each one of these vectors
and assigns a class to it so this would
be deer right here ok so stage 1
proposes regions of interest along with
features then stage 2 takes each of
these regions of interests and
classifies them basically
and I guess there there's there's many
in-between stage like this is massively
simplified there's not maximum
suppression there is kind of an
alignment stage where you can refine the
bounding box and so on but in essence
these are two stages and you can see
that this system here it goes in between
the two stages so all of this right here
we shove in between the two stages so
we'll still use the stage one and we'll
still use the stage two but in between
in this thing right here we'll try to
sort of pimp these features such that
the stage two detector has an easier
time classifying okay so we're going to
pimp these features by incorporating in
because these features right now if we
just do it vanilla these are just from
the current frame and we're going to add
to them information from other frames of
the same camera and we're going to do it
in two different ways so the first way
as you can see here the first way is
this short term memory and the second
way is the long term memory now the two
are slightly different as you can guess
the short term memory is going to be
only over a short time period around the
current frame and the long term memory
is going to be basically across a very
long time horizon into the past you can
see we're trying to classify this blue
frame right here that what we call the
key frame so what we'll do is we'll run
it through stage one cool so we have
features for each region of interest and
then you can see this goes here and
through these residual connections this
goes into stage two over here
so basically stage two still receives
the same input it receives whatever
stage one outputs for the key frame but
we're going to add to that twice so
we're going to add two things as I as I
said so the short-term memory is added
right here now how do we build the
short-term memory
we built the short-term memory simply by
considering all the frames around the
keyframe and this you can see right here
the current window around the keyframe
which can be like one frame around it or
two frames or three frames just a few
frames around the current frame and this
can be fairly helpful as we said for
example if the deer moves a bit the car
moves a bit you know it gets into a
slightly different lighting and so on
this can help us very much to to
classify the current keyframe if we also
have features from the surrounding
frames so for each of these surrounding
frames we also run them through the
stage one detector to also extract
regions of interest and that all of
these features go into this memory
short-term memory bank right here
there's different strategies you don't
always have to extract all of the
regions of interest you can also extract
just the top one and so on or you can
extract the mean since these are fairly
you know consistent the cameras at the
same place there are many ways you can
do this but what you ultimately end up
with is a short-term memory bank that
kind of is so you'll have a Mac and you
have lots of these feature vectors in
here for your region your regions of
interest of the surrounding frames now
if this here if this here is your
occluded deer right so this is the half
occluded deer and you want to consider
information from the surrounding frames
maybe in the next frame so maybe this is
three frames like one two three and two
is the key frame maybe in the next frame
the deer moves a bit and you see its
nose and that this particular region of
interest here is relevant so how do you
know how do you now get from this entire
memory this feature vector that would be
helpful and the answer is you get it
through an attention mechanism you can
see that right here
the way
the short-term memory is added is
through this attention block they
describe the attention block right here
it is a fairly standard attention
mechanism so I've done a video on
attention is all you need if you don't
know what an attention mechanism is go
check it out but you can see it's it's
very very standard so you have these
input features which are the features
that come from the keyframe and you have
the context features which are all the
features in your memory bank you encode
the input features with into a query
using a fully connected layers and the
context features in two keys and then
you match the queries with the keys and
the softmax in order to get a weighting
over the context features and then you a
granade the values from the context
features so this is a standard attention
mechanism what does it mean it basically
means that each of these vectors right
here they will emit a key that kind of
describes what kind of information is
contained in that vector the vector over
here will emit a query that describes
what sort of information it is looking
for to in order to describe what's in
the region of interest as well as
possible and then you simply match the
query with the keys to determine which
key fits best to that query and
whichever one fits best let's say this
one here then you take that vector from
the memory bank and incorporate it
together with your current information
that you already have so that's how you
address things that from other frames
using an attention mechanism okay now if
this were all you know we could train
this right now we could train all of
this because all of this is
differentiable right this stage one
detector right here is differentiable it
goes here and here you know the
information the attention mechanism is
differentiable the stage two detector is
differentiable all differentiable
cool we can train this end-to-end now
what's the problem the problem is this
long-term memory right here
so in this memory ideally we would want
to fit let's say an entire day an entire
week or even an entire month of data
from one of these cameras and it's just
not feasible that we expand this current
window here to an entire month or an
entire week for many of those of those
cameras because even though they have a
low frame rate and so on it's still too
much in order to then be all
differentiable all backpropagate able
and so on
so we can't really back prop in for this
long-term memory in essence what we want
to do is exactly the same we want to
build up a memory of all of the regions
of interest or maybe selected regions or
all of the best regions of interest
whatever heuristic strategy we have of
the past whatever this camera has seen
let's say in the last month or in the
current week or something like this we
want to build all of this up and then
use an attention mechanism just the same
in order to incorporate it but we we
have to come up with these things right
here in some other way then a way where
we can back prop so we can't really use
this stage one detector right here
because this is this is the one we're
training and so we have to back prop
through it
now an easy proposal is to simply use it
any way but do like a stop gradient on
it so we don't back prop through it that
is one way but this the paper decides on
a different way the paper decides that
all of the all of the past basically
right here right here and so on we'll
take a pre trained object detector so
not the one we're training currently but
we'll trick take a pre trained one that
was pre trained either on something like
Coco which is an object detection data
set or you can pre train it on Coco and
then
fine-tune it on the task you're
interested in in a single frame fashion
in word for whatever way we'll take a
pre trained object detector or region of
interest extractor and that will give us
for each frame in the past will give us
also the regions of interest along with
the features okay and these are the
features that we then go and put in to
put into the memory bank sorry my tablet
just crashed a bit there we go
okay so we'll take a pre trained
extractor right here that will give us
features for regions of interest we'll
put that into the memory bank and then
we will use an attention mechanism to
incorporate it now the attention
mechanism we can train but we cannot
train the extractor for the features and
this is the difference to the short-term
memory where we can actually train the
feature extractor in order to help us
with you know building the memory now
the memory is simply built without a
goal in mind basically and the attention
Mehcad the attention mechanism basically
has to learn that it doesn't work with
features that are meant for its task it
works with features that have been
originally created for a different tasks
and they're not going to change but as
we'll see this you know can be handled
so that's what they do they incorporate
short-term and long-term memory into
their stage 2 prediction and then the
stage 2 prediction simply takes in all
of those features and classifies the
class of the object and that's the
architecture of context or CNN it's our
CNN with long and short term context so
they describe a very different ways of
you know how they built the memory and
so on how they build the features I
didn't I kind of glossed over this right
now there's a lot of consideration in
building these thing and you have to
look at the paper how
exactly do this I'm more interested in
the high-level architecture and the sort
of ideas behind it so when they do this
they do outperform the they do
outperform the current or the single
frame baselines by quite a bit
so this SS and this CCT are these
wildlife datasets
whereas this CC I think this is the city
something city cam these are this street
dataset as you can see they do
outperform the single frame baseline by
quite a bit now interesting as you can
see right here as they increase the time
horizon of this long term memory so they
they can all they can now choose how
much information do they want to put in
that long-term memory as they increase
the time horizon for one minute one hour
one day and so on the performance goes
up and up and up which is you know a
strong indication that these features
actually help from the from the timer
eyes because you don't have more
parameters you simply increase the
amount of information in the memory bank
and if the performance goes up you can
make a very strong claim that these
these this is actually due to the fact
that you have more information in that
memory bank couldn't really guess any
other explanation right here so they
they do it they do investigate different
memory strategies they do a lot of
ablations right here where they also say
okay what if we only have the short-term
attention what if we only have the
long-term attention what do only if we
only have self attention that means
attention only into the current frame
but of they are across regions of
interest that's interesting if you have
like a herd of animals and so on and
they all help but as you can see the
long-term attention tends to help the
most in this data set and the short term
attention help helps a lot in this data
set if each is compared to the other
owner these are two different metrics
not datasets sorry about that but in
essence it helps the most when you
combine the two and that's you know
that's pretty cool to see so they do
some qualitative results which I find
very interesting for example they can
visualize what the attention weights of
their models are so here you always have
a very long time frame I think an entire
month in this in this memory bank of the
long-term memory now in the top
classification you see the large thing
here the large frame is the one you
actually want to classify and the other
frames are the frames where the top
attention score is so that the attention
weights are the highest so here in order
to classify this what does the model pay
attention to or which other frames does
the model pay attention to and you can
see right here they are all spread
across the entire month here is the
timeline the most attended two pictures
are spread across the entire month and
almost or all of them actually have that
warthog in here so this must be like its
regular route and the model recognizes
that and pulls in information from all
these other images in order to correctly
classify it here on the other hand on
the next example this gazelle and tablet
crashed right here it also puts all the
all the weight on top of the images of
that same gazelle but you can see maybe
that gazelle was only there for this one
particular moment and all the pictures
this camera has of it is you know in the
very few moments that the gazelle was
around you can see they all come here
from the same point in time or very very
close points in time
and you can see that it puts a lot of
weight on wherever the gazelle is so you
know that's a pretty strong indication
that it actually learns to pull in the
correct information be that from long
time horizon or from a short time
horizon if necessary you can also see
right here they visualize the top
attention where the top attention
weights go in terms of how long the
frames where the attention goes to is
away from the frame that they are trying
to classify so on these graphics are
somewhat kind of weird to interpret this
here always means how much is the total
time of the buffer so the memory buffer
here contains always pictures from the
total from one hour before until one
hour after the key frame you want to
classify so this is the frame you want
to classify at minute zero and the
memory buffer contains images from 60
minutes before to 60 minutes after so
it's it's not real time right you go
back to your through your footage and
you try to classify so you can also pull
out images from the future you can see
there's most attention is on the current
frame which makes sense
you've trying to classify it the current
frame and then kind of falls off as you
go further and further away and this is
across the entire data set so this is
not a specific example which also makes
sense probably in most of the time the
relevant information is you know next
closer in time rather than farther away
but also you can see that the
distribution is pretty spread out so it
it makes the model makes use of the
entire range of time and you can see
that throughout even if you have an
entire day in the buffer or two days
even if you have entire week before and
week after in the buffer and even if you
have an entire month here and especially
if you look at when you have an entire
week in the buffer you can see the
periodicity
through the days so that means the model
tends to pay attention to images that
are from the same time of day compared
to the current keyframe that's fairly
fairly good indication that the model
has actually learned to address these
this memory by its content right now
night and day isn't super difficult
because you can just go on the
brightness and so on but still it's
pretty cool to see that this is actually
happening
they do have some failure cases of the
single frame model that their model is
able to handle up here and if they make
a lot of sense so here you can see that
there is an object that's moving out of
frame and the single frame detector
wasn't able to recognize this but
probably because it's you know moving
out of rave whereas this new this
context our CNN is able to detect it
probably because it looked at the frame
just before it where the car was
somewhere back here and it could
correctly classified well that's well
just disregard my drawings here it
managed to recognize this animal in the
back
whereas this old model the single frame
model hasn't also probably by looking
either at frames next to it or by
looking at other frames of herds of
animals and realizing that usually when
there's two elephants there's more here
you can see that the object highly
occluded so we're talking about the
object like at the very edge of the
frame object poorly lit this is
particularly impressive and also an
example where the animals are often in
herds and if you see one deer the
likelihood that there's other deer it's
very high in this particular camera and
by aggregating information from
different frames you can see that maybe
it's always the same patch of the ER
that comes by
and here the single-frame detector
detects this patch here as a vehicle
where it shouldn't and of course the new
model the contacts are CNN is able to
recognize that this is present in all of
the frames and in most frames the single
the single object detector doesn't
detect it as a vehicle and so it can
kind of carry over that information now
you can already see sort of what the
downsides might be if the single object
detector is like very very very sure
that this is in a single frame that this
is a car it could carry over that
information to the other frame so even
though the single frame detector might
have failed in that particular frame if
it fails super hard it might you know
shout that to all the other frames
basically dominate the memory saying
like look this is a car I'm like pretty
sure and it will carry over that
information to all of the other frames
and they say in one of the in one of
these high confidence mistakes it
basically detected the same tree as a
giraffe over and over again what I find
particularly interesting is they do look
at so here they have this this curve of
on the bottom you have confidence
thresholds so how confident the model is
and on the y-axis you have the number of
false positives and you can see that in
the low confidence regime the context or
CNN has lower false positives than the
single frame detector and the green line
here is when you only have positive
boxes so when you only include regions
of interest where there is an actual
object which in this case is sort of
hurtful you also want the regions of
interest where there is nothing because
that helps you avoid false positives in
other frames that's why the orange line
is below the green line but strangely
here in
high-confidence regime you can see that
the single frame model has fewer false
positives than the context our CNN and I
like the text that they have to this in
Figure seven we can see that adding
empty representations reduces the number
of false positives across all confidence
threshold compared to the same model
with only positive representations we
investigated the 100 highest confidence
false positives from context our sinan
and found that in almost all of them in
97 out of a hundred the model had
correctly found and classified animals
that were missed by human annotators so
basically these the these graphs are
even under estimating how good that
model is because the model is seems
appears to be better than the human
annotators of the test set I find that I
find that to be pretty pretty impressive
and here you can see failure modes where
they say for example when exploring the
confident false positives on these
snapshots Serengeti dataset yeah yeah
yeah the three out of a hundred images
so whatever was not fail human failure
were we're context our CNN erroneously
detected an animal where were all of the
same tree highly confidently predicted
to be a giraffe so this is a failure
mode when when the model is highly
confident it might spill that over to
other frames because we now aggregate
the information within the same camera
across the frames well to be said of
course they're trained test split is
such that there's not the same camera in
the training data as in the testing data
they have different different entirely
different cameras in the testing data
than in the training data just so there
is no information leakage yeah so that
is the that's the model right here how
it works it's it's pretty cool it kind
of wedges itself in between
any single frame object detector that
has these two stages and you know it's a
pretty neat idea to bring in context
from from even past or even the future
of the same camera just a quick glance
at the appendix they have lots of
different examples right here in one
example their camera kind of fell over
and they say well it still worked the
camera with the system was still able to
kind of do attention across this failure
this kind of tipping over of the camera
they have more examples right here which
I find pretty impressive like these
super low light things where it
correctly detects like the opossum and
yeah I invite you to check out the paper
the code they say should be out soon and
I'll see you next time bye bye